c'est l'heure de la pause déjeuner à
navoti société spécialisée dans les
compléments alimentaires à
Neuillé-Pont-Pierre les légumes dans les
assiettes sont produits à seulement
quelques mètres dans le jardin de
l'entreprise ce sont les salariés de
navoti qui cultivent les légumes à tour
de rôle et entre deux réunions il n'y a
alors plus de distinction entre les
services tout le monde met la main à la
terre
chacun on n'a pas toujours le temps d'y
aller donc en fait on se remplace aussi
on fait toujours en sorte qu'il y ait du
monde au potager pour pouvoir après
nourrir
certains d'entre nous au repas de midi
voilà c'est pour participe aussi du
repas du coup
pour le PDG de navoti le potager est un
moyen de souder l'équipe tout en se
reconnectant avec la nature ça crée
aussi des moments de partage qui sont
vraiment atypiques dans la vie d'une
entreprise le fait de se retrouver tous
les services la logistique le conseil la
direction ensemble au même moment au
potager pour développer le potager
n'avotit a fait appel au service de
Christophe Chesneau
ça c'est la Sucrine du Berry c'est le
potimarron enfin c'est la butternut
local c'est très très bon la beauté il y
en a deux on va les séparer par contre
avec sa société il accompagne les
entreprises et les aides à installer et
entretenir leur potager collaboratif
pour produire des légumes bio quand les
gens nous appellent ils nous disent
toujours la même chose ils nous disent
ça commence excusez-moi j'ai pas la main
verte je leur dis non c'est pas ça c'est
qu'en fait le potager c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'on pense et si ça n'a
pas poussé c'est pas parce que vous avez
pas la main verte c'est parce que sans
doute vous avez fait des erreurs sans
vous en rendre compte et nous on est là
pour vous aider pour les salariés les
potagers collaboratifs permettent de
prendre un moment pour serrer l'esprit
au milieu d'une journée de travail et
manger des légumes qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
cultivés et sans doute le plus
satisfaisant